got black again against never felt em I
always have good luck against this
player I don't know why check did we
have this recently no okay yeah he a
divorce is coming I think f5 is actually
move it looks completely bonkers but I
don't know he played this quite quickly
so he probably knows the stuff where he
does and I don't I just know that this
is a move f5 it's not as terrible as it
looks and it looks pretty terrible huh
so how is that playing may be here 95
okay I was thinking that e5 maybe Wow
yes okay so t5 I have to teach every
kind of feeling like a Hector's on the
port and again in the Blitz game not
over the board game it looks extremely
dangerous for me but on the other hand
if he doesn't have something very
forceful quickly i'm very ok he can take
your sex I just wonder it's that really
dangerous in mind if I just put and we
just develop here I mean I have seven
like and Castle short this is a non-move
really yeah it's moving he's moving the
night all over the place ok c6 is a tech
though I don't want to give him that if
I can avoid it it should be 78
we should be six I mean I'm totally fine
after Bishop is 626 let's do it come on
let's play it simple now this I didn't
even consider thought this is crap
anyway the night has more squares I
thought Queen takes was the only move
huh now threatening Bishop g7 and
probably also stuff on the King side
okay so here Bishop c7 and queen d 6 is
probably quite strong but you can also
probably sacrifice on age 26
I think it should we check if not it's
unlucky really I mean check something
that Bishop c7 was probably just great
anyway but I thought his gang killed him
threatening made and g3 um yeah I
thought rook f2 is one way maybe Bishop
f4 might might save him but the other
thing on g3 I had Queenie fire this is
what I saw Queenie 54 Queen age 5 and I
didn't think that would be able to that
is defensible but ok let's look at g3
look f2 awesome Bishop f4 is the only
possible flight resigned we just
resigned they are maybe also night f2 I
mean there there are many ways of
killing him probably yeah so I was
thinking here but then Bishop f4 maybe
he's still at the engine is merciless
this should be cemetery that that tech
is just too strong this is this I wasn't
totally sure because of Quincy six but
now check I mean those pieces are not
doing much not at the warning here I can
probably check check check yeah forgot
to switch on the nettles I'm sorry yeah
that was pretty strange game yeah five I
know that this is a this is not
unplayable yeah it is risky though
deform takes and he went night
five so hmm I was also thinking about
this yeah but check probably I'm
escaping it looks a bit strange but
should work so ok this one and I'm
played Bishop e7 I expected 96 but he
took here immediately one point is that
this is so d5 has to be played and now
see for I suggested by stockfish that
makes sense it does make sense think we
need for queen bees eggs and these
exactly 66 doesn't do it ready ya think
it's 90 of seven is simply no threat and
I'm just developing now nanded this lost
enormous time yeah I thought he has to
do this my intention was rook c8
actually does this disposition and I've
got a nice bishop pair center and so on
this is probably not working at all yeah
[Music]
91 this was the the simple alternative
actually and then queen to d6 it also
looks pretty awful check with the set
that must work fine i just have
everything in the attack g3 just quickly
this one I was kind of yeah it's really
crazy he's so far away from defending
like something like this you just attack
here
it's funny how bad these pieces on okay
thanks for watching